اخبار الحرب على غزه بايجاز من الجليل
الاعلى اهلا بكم مع استمرار المعارك في
وسط قطاع غزه في مخيمي البريج والنصيرات
ابو عبيده يقول ان الاحتلال اخفق خلال 100
يوم في تحقيق اهدافه بما فيها تحرير
الاسرى ويكشف ان مصير العديد منهم اضحى
مجهولا ويرجح مقتلهم بسبب القصف والجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول انه يواصل لتصفيه قاده
حماس وان التقديرات تشير الى ان معظمهم لا
يزالون احياء عشرات الشهداء والجرحى في
قصف الاحتلال الاسرائيلي المتواصل على
مدينه غزه ومناطق في خان يونس جنوبي
القطاع ومخيمات في وسطه ووزاره الصحه تعلن
ارتفاع عدد الشهداء الى اكثر من
4 الفا اكثر من ثلثيهم نساء واطفال مقتل
اسرائيليه واصابه اكثر من 18 اخرين بينهم
اربعه بحاله خطيره في حادثتي دهس وطعن في
رعنانا الشماليه الابي ومصادر عبريه تشير
الى ان الحدث وقع في ثلاثه اماكن مختلفه
وتحقيق اولي للشرطه الاسرائيليه يقول ان
شخصا طعن امراه واستولى على مركبتها ثم
دهس اخرين في اكثر من موقع الخلافات تحتدم
في مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي عضو المجلس
ايزنكوت يدعو للتحلي بالشجاعه وابرام صفقه
تعيد الاسر وزير الدفاع جلنت يناقض
نتنياهو ويقول ان وجود سلطه فلسطينيه قويه
تعد مصلحه امنيه اسرائيليه وتزايد الدعوات
في الكنيست الى المضي في صفقات تبادل حتى
لو كان
الثمن
مؤلما الى
اللقاء
ه